hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question for
one of my form readers jenka who was
impressed with the forum posts and
videos and articles that i was sharing
on my site and was asking how did I have
time to do this while running my
business as well and I said that it was
through having good systems and I create
a quick video to explain some of the
systems for those three things so in
terms of the videos I get a lot of video
requests I do a video pretty much every
day right now and it comes from people
writing in asking me questions and I
love doing this it's part of why I
started my business I love helping
entrepreneurs and mostly videos I don't
make any money from it's just I love
helping you guys out feeds my passion
and so I wanted to find a way to do this
without it taking up all day every day
answering questions so with the videos
what happens is somebody asking a
question and this is increasingly coming
from a lot of different sources so it
used to be just email but now I'm
getting questions from Twitter Facebook
Google+ YouTube forum so I'm getting a
lot of questions coming in but I'll
usually do right away if I think it
would lend itself well to a video is all
right back and say i'll create a quick
video for you as a response so what i
used to do is give them response on the
spot and that was great but it took up
my time and then also it only helped
them or thought by creating videos it
also helped everybody else who may have
a similar challenge and they can learn
from my thoughts on it as well so i'll
write back to everybody right away just
to say i'll create a quick video
response for you so they know that
something's coming then what I'll do is
once a week usually on Wednesdays I
start filming so right now it's a
wednesday morning and what i'll do is
i'll print off all of my sheets of
questions so here if I reach down here
you can see we have three pages of
questions here are lots of different
questions that have come in from readers
and there's yours yet guess I'm
answering this one right here and what
I'll do is I'll create quick notes so i
don't know if you can kind of see it
from where you are here but i'll just
jot down some notes on what I want to
say I'll print up the question and come
up with some ideas of what I want to say
and then I'll either just get in front
of the cameras are talking about it or
I'll get to the whiteboard and create a
few notes and write them down but what
happens this really works well for me is
doing this once a week so I always do it
on a Wednesday morning then I found out
that I was editing myself but I wasn't
that great an editor and I always
believed in boots dropping at the start
so do as much as you can yourself figure
out if you want to keep doing it or not
figure out if there's a way to make
money doing it or not before you start
spending a lot of money try to make some
money coming in before you spend a lot
of money so I was doing all the editing
myself and so the first video is if you
look back at my history are pretty bad
but the future videos have gotten better
and and we've gotten better equipment
and I have an editor Assad who sent on
my videos to so high side is watching
this and editing these videos and
basically happens is after I film once a
week I will edit all the video sorry I
won't edit the videos I'll save the
videos in the in a folder in dropbox and
that goes to sod he works on them and
send them back to me then we upload them
to youtube youtube and with YouTube what
you can do is you can schedule when you
want a video to come out so instead of
having to go in every day and post on
YouTube as soon as i get my videos back
from Saad i will just log in and upload
them all to youtube and set them to go
out on different dates so you can set
them the go you know one day at a time
and schedule what time you want them to
come out so you can set all that up in
advance and then as a days the one they
get they get released so that process
works well it takes me some time every
and wednesday morning to put all these
videos together but it works well and it
saves me some time so you may you may
notice that i have kind of the same
shirt on a lot when i'm doing the videos
because i do them all on one day and
then i slowly release them out over over
the week so that's the videos hopefully
that is helpful for you so i'm a big
believer in kind of chunking time so
that if you do the same task
over and over again better to do it all
at once then to do little bits every day
so for sending a video I gotta get a
nice shirt on I got to get the camera
set up I gotta get the microphone setup
gotta get in the mindset of ok gonna
answer some questions now and it's a lot
easier to do it of them all back to back
to back to back then to do a little bit
every day because all that set-up time
physically to create all do you know the
camera and all that but also get into
the mindset to be ready to do the videos
takes up a lot of time so it's better to
chunk it if you came in terms of the
forum posts what I like to do as much as
I can is leverage my content leverage
content so what I do with my forum posts
is I will log in usually once a day and
try to see what questions are on there
well how am I build their answer some
questions just to get a pulse of what's
going on one great thing you can do is
you grow your businesses get some help
get people helping you out so for my
forms we have a great forum moderator
his name is GT you watches most of these
videos so hi GT we love you you're great
and GT is in the forums every day and
it's very active and is answering
questions and responding with people
which is super helpful for us and also
our forum moderators so yank I know
you've been a floor model for a while so
that's all really helpful and it means I
don't have to be in the form every day
all day so getting people to help you
out is fantastic what I do post to my
forms what I try to do is also leverage
that content elsewhere so I will tweet
about some posts I will if I create
these videos will post them in the form
so i get them on youtube and i also get
to my forms some of the stuff i post on
facebook will also put in the forums so
having that ability to leverage the
content in multiple places helps because
you only create the content once and you
can share it in a couple of other places
so leveraging content is great the other
thing that also helps is having a
schedule so when you're creating content
at the start it may just be whenever you
have time but it's really helpful as you
get going is to see what's working what
isn't working and how you can create a
Content schedule around the the content
that you want to publish so for example
what we do on our site at least right
now
is every day will post a famous
entrepreneur quote and that'll go up on
my Facebook page and it also go in the
forms so you'll see a quote of famous
entrepreneur we found that those tend to
pull well and people like them and I get
inspired by them as well I will also
post the YouTube posts almost every day
on the forum so we have a new video
coming out so think about your own
content strategy you don't necessarily
need to have something going out three
or four times a day like we do but maybe
it's one today or maybe it's three times
a week so you know set out what's going
to happen on every day make sure
something you can stick to and then as
you see this working you might be able
to find a way to delegate some of those
tasks off to other people and you can
focus on what you're really good at as
well so that's really helped us with the
farms and then in terms of reading
content and how do I find time to read
all these articles and share them with
you I do a couple of things first i use
google reader so what I'll do here is I
subscribe to a number of different feeds
from blogs that I like reading it could
be you know tech tech blogs like
TechCrunch or entrepreneur blogs and you
know personal interest blogs as well
that I like reading and I'll sit they'll
come in out of mind to my google reader
and if i have time when I'm you know
eating my breakfast then i might check
out some of those and what I do is if I
really like an article I'll save it to
my Instapaper so Instapaper Instapaper
is an app that you can get your ipad and
ever since I got my iPad I've been a
huge reader thanks to instapaper so what
I'll do with Google Reader i'll just
quickly browse through the articles that
I like those that I like will be put
into my instant paper that will be saved
on my iPad and then you have them
offline for whenever you're ready to
read so what I do I often walk to work
if I'm ever waiting in line anywhere
I'll just pull up my iPad and I'll start
reading and such a my walk to work it's
about 15 minutes in 15 minutes home so I
have a good half an hour every day to be
able to get some reading done and start
going through my articles the right
thing about instant papers then you can
also share so what I'll do here
I cope with a lot of ideas from the
content that I read and what I'll do if
it's an article that I want to share
with just some friends I can email it
right for my iPad and it's an article
that I want to share with my form
readers or on Facebook then I'll send
myself an email with the one sentence
that I want to use to describe the
content so I'll often send articles out
with one sentence I'll tweet about it
I'll collect a list at the end of the
week and i'll post in the forums and
i'll also post that same link in my
facebook page as well so again
leveraging the content but using
Instapaper and my iPad to get a lot more
reading done the other one that I use
for my ipad is service calls it-- which
is free it's an online magazine and what
it does is collect content based on
different categories that you like so
you can pick off technology and travel
and entrepreneurship and Google or
whatever it is that you want to start
tracking and it delivers you content
every day based on what's popular online
and what I'll do is hurt to learn what
you like and what you don't like and so
the articles from certain blogs that you
read all the time there they'll show
more of it and you can say I don't want
to see articles from this company
anymore this blog anymore so you'll see
less of it or none of it and I usually
do a quick check of sight every morning
because that that changes every day
where my google reader if I don't get to
it then I can always get to it the next
day and it's always there for me what
site is always kind of updating constant
so what site what I'll do is I'll
quickly browse through the articles
every day and if I like anything again
I'll save it to instapaper Zidan
Instapaper have the ability to talk to
each other and then I'll end up reading
it when I'm walking again so walk into
work or standing in line or whenever I
have some extra time and once the back
relax and read so that's how I do my
reading and posting good articles so
yeah I hope that helps um I hope that
visual display there was useful as well
if you guys like this is the system that
i use if you like the video i'd love to
hear you have to say if you want to
leave a comment under video and i always
appreciate when you give it a like and a
thumbs up so please do that below
and I look forward to seeing you on the
next episode
you